Ціни на газ на міжнародному ринку стрімко зростають вже не перший тиждень.
На початку жовтня вартість блакитного палива сягнула позначки в майже 2 тисячі доларів.
Це вдесятеро дорожче порівняно з минулим роком.
На думку експертів, до такого безпрецедентного стрибка цін призвела сукупність різних факторів.
По-перше, на ринку енергоносіїв утворився дефіцит газу.
Деякі газові родовища в Європі з екологічних міркувань скорочують
або повністю припиняють видобуток блакитного палива.
Приміром, до 2023 року виведуть з експлуатації найбільше родовище в Європі -
у провінції Гронінген у Нідерландах. А у газотранспортній системі Норвегії тривають
ремонтно-профілактичні роботи, через які та сильно скоротила поставки газу в Європу.
За даними ЗМІ, газосховища ЄС нині заповнені на 71 відсоток.
Це менше, ніж у минулі роки. Водночас світова економіка почала відновлюватися
після пандемії коронавірусу й попит на енергоносії сильно зріс, особливо в Азії.
Тож, значна частина обсягів скрапленого газу, на який розраховували в Європі,
пішла саме туди - навіть за ще вищими цінами.
"Газпром" постачає близько третини природного газу, який споживають у Європі.
Німеччина імпортує з Росії навіть більше половини потрібного їй блакитного палива.
З огляду на таку залежність від російського газу, саме Москву деякі політики в Європі
звинуватили у газовій кризі. Вважається, що "Газпром" таким чином домагається
якнайшвидшого дозволу на початок експлуатації газогону "Північний потік-2".
Політичний тиск чиниться для того, щоб "Північний потік-2" був запущений якомога швидше.
Низки європейських дозволів все ще бракує, і я вважаю, що президент Путін
просто грає у свою гру з поставками газу до Німеччини і Центральної Європи.
Москва ж заперечує відповідальність за дефіцит газу. В "Газпромі" стверджують,
що всі зобов'язання щодо постачання вони виконують.
Від початку року на закордонні ринки постачалися обсяги газу, що є близькими до рекордних.
Ми наростили поставки на найбільший ринок споживання - у Німеччину -
на третину порівняно з минулим роком.
Берлінський експерт із газового ринку Німеччини і ЄС Гайко Ломан теж не вважає "Газпром"
винним у газовій кризі. Він зауважує, що обсяги видобутку газу у російського монополіста обмежені,
а при цьому внутрішній попит в самій країні дуже високий.
Не варто вірити в подібні теорії змови. Особисто я проявляю стриманість у цьому питанні,
тому що цьому немає жодних доказів. Звичайно, є певний збіг.
Так, у самому "Газпромі" очікували, що цього року - не пізніше початку року -
можна буде використовувати "Північний потік-2". Це було очікувано,
адже трубопровід готовий. Цілком можливо, що в "Газпромі" недооцінили зусилля,
необхідні для сертифікації.
Водночас експерт вважає, що якщо "Північний потік-2" буде запущений, то ціни впадуть,
в тому числі з психологічних причин.
Уже тепер видно, як уважно учасники ринку стежать за тим, що відбувається.
Кожне повідомлення про російський газогін, про "Північний потік-2",
негайно призводить до зміни ціни.
Тим часом російський президент Володимир Путін звинуватив у газовій кризі -
цитата - "так званих експертів у Брюсселі", які, за його словами,
форсували біржову торгівлю газом, згортаючи довгострокові контракти,
що, на думку російського президента, виявилося помилковим.
Тож, судячи з усього, перезимувати в теплі Європі цього року буде значно дорожче.
Як реагують на це пересічні німці?
Так, я знаю, що ціни зростають, але напевно рахунок за газ прийде
наприкінці року. Доплатити доведеться.
У нас дуже багато газових приладів: котел, газовий камін, ми готуємо на газі.
Нам це важливо, бо ми цим користуємося. І нам пощастило - у нас є фінансові резерви.
Звичайно, треба стежити за динамікою цін. Ми в курсі, що ціни на енергоносії зростають.
Нам до пенсії недовго залишилося, тож треба це враховувати.
І ми дещо стурбовані. Не панікуємо, але стурбовані.
З глузду з'їхати можна... Чим я маю опалювати? Нафтою не можна - заборонили.
Бензин забороняють, ціни на газ стрімко зростають. Чим людям накажете опалювати?
Нам що - за вугілля братися? Чи дровами? Так ми у кам'яний вік повернемося.
У Брюсселі заспокоюють й обіцяють подбати про громадян ЄС.
По-перше, наш негайний пріоритет - це захист європейських споживачів,
особливо найбільш вразливих. По-друге, ми повинні зробити нашу енергетичну систему
більш підготовленою і стійкою, щоб не довелося зіткнутися з подібною ситуацією в майбутньому.
Держави-члени ЄС можуть надати вразливим споживачам фінансову підтримку
для компенсації зростання цін.
ЄС буде проводити політику абсолютної нетерпимості до будь-яких ринкових маніпуляцій
або спекуляцій. Ми розслідуємо ознаки будь-якої можливої
антиконкурентної поведінки на енергетичному ринку.
Тим часом економічний експерт DW, як і багато інших аналітиків, переконаний,
що "Газпром" таки свідомо загострював ситуацію і сприяв нинішньому дефіциту газу в Європі,
щоб якнайшвидше протиснути отримання дозволу для запуску "Північного потоку-2".
Додаткових обсягів це Європі не принесе, бо "Північний потік-2",
так само як і "Турецький потік", будувався для того, щоб пустити ними ті обсяги газу,
які йдуть через Україну. Задача Москви, зважаючи на все це,
не тільки протиснути "Північний потік-2", а й поховати спотовий, біржовий ринок для газу
і змусити європейців знову укладати з Росією довгострокові контракти.
Якщо ЄС таки піде на довгострокові контракти з "Газпромом", то, на думку оглядачів,
фактично доведеться відмовитися від амбітних планів щодо захисту клімату
та відмови від викопних джерел енергії,
а це, зауважують експерти, малоймовірно.